hi gobo hi moki i want
i want to tell you my name is christina
radish which i tell you i'm not making
up it really is my name you guys are
fragiles i'm a radish yeah we are very
very excited to talk to you silly
creature radish never been interviewed
by a radish before no
actual radish yeah but but but we're
happy with this yeah very happy yeah
well i know you guys love radishes so
i'm hoping that earns me some bonus
points yes it does
what do you love about radishes what was
it like the first time you ate a radish
oh wow
it starts pretty young i mean i i
remember being a little teeny fraggle
and monk traveling matt said you got to
try this it tastes so delicious you know
because when when you're a little
fragile you pretty much just start on
dozer constructions which are made out
of radishes yeah so we haven't really
had anything else yeah but didn't eat
your first real radish yeah you know oh
it's so good from the earth from the
gorg's garden i can remember it like it
was yesterday give us a second here
christina radish
[Music]
radish memories
okay radish
do you have any favorite uses for
radishes is there a favorite way you
like to eat them especially now um
you know a souffle is always nice uber
makes an amazing router souffle he does
he makes it he also makes a great bullet
bath
yep how do you say it
i think that's pretty good yeah oh you
know also i i like a sensible radish
gumbo yeah sometimes if i'm feeling
simple i'll just slice a radish put it
on some radish bread toast oh that's
nice yeah simple uncomplicated
the radish as you may know christina the
radish does not need a lot of adornment
and there's endless uses
we should write a book yeah
it sounds like you could do a whole
cookbook on what you can do with the
radish
what a great idea
wow you know christina rad is silly
creature christina radish we could write
it with you yeah you write it with us
yeah
i i could help you write it but i have
to say i have never cooked with one so
i'd have to leave that up to you guys
you never you've never cooked with
radishes wow we are focusing on the
radishes so what's blowing my mind wow
blowing my mind i'm in shock
well uncle travelingmat tells you
stories about silly creatures in outer
space but you've only ever heard them
and not seen them so what would you
imagine that a silly creature might look
like
well five eyes
couple five ice yeah probably
seventeen arms slippers for feet well
you know i i have seen the silly
creature that lives in in the portal to
outer space
yeah
and and that silly creature it seems
really nice you know so but i haven't
seen beyond that i hope to someday you
know i'm pretty brave so i might go yeah
i'll go out outer space
explorer yes
he's my brave dance yeah yeah do it
yes look very breathe very very bright
i'm getting sort of oh sorry i didn't
mean to whack you with my tail sorry do
one more time okay
sorry
i'm fine
just a little prank oh wait but
christina radish christina radish wait
you know because we're talking to you
through loser tubes we can't see you but
but but do do silly creatures also like
radishes and like to explore we
definitely i mean i i would hope people
like radishes otherwise you know that
might be hard for me but
yes
i i would say people like radishes on on
salads
especially oh
salads
he likes a sensible radish sounds
amazing yeah so i'm going to try that
with a nice saffron dressing
with a lemony it's actually saffron
defrost no it's not like bulla booze
well how about you mokey would you ever
want to see or meet a silly creature oh
yes i'm all about connecting i would
love to connect with a silly creature
and ask all kinds of questions like like
like what what's a pancake
things like that
deep things yeah yeah what did you think
the first time uncle traveling matt told
you about visiting outer space and silly
creatures did it seem scary did it seem
exciting
well i i mean i'd be lying if i were to
say it wasn't a little scary sounding
you know i mean i don't say that in
front of you and moki you know but but
it's true i mean it sounds uh kind of
scary but exciting and adventurous you
know there's things i want to see he
told me about a magical place called the
uh what's it what's it called the the
subway
subway way that sounds exciting that
does yeah
and there was another place you told me
about what was it called it's called the
beach
beach yeah covered with with something
called sand
yeah sounds like a magical place wow
there are definitely a lot of adventures
to be had oh sure yeah yeah and i think
most of the adventures always have a
little bit of scariness to them but
mostly fun that's the best kind you know
because because you got you know when
fraggles gets scared our tails here see
see they see the kind of the fringy part
here at the end it's called our beluvius
and when we get scared our belubias goes
like that no
you see it again
like that
well if i am ever able to go on my own
adventure and make it to the frago hole
and and come visit you guys at fraggle
rock what is the first thing you would
want to show me in front of the pond
right back there yeah we want to take
you for a good swim in the in the
fraggle pond for sure yeah and we want
to announce to the great hall there's a
radish here you gotta
she's here
okay she's here
so thank you for that oh sure well you
know i mean we'd love to bring you down
here to fraggle rock yeah you're always
welcome
well what is the best thing about being
a fragile
oh
the 30-minute work week is pretty great
yeah we only work 30 minutes a week it
is exhausting oh man
yeah also to singing we love to sing
yeah we sing dance and play the rest of
the time
every morning
every day
every evening
calling me away
fine exhausted oh yeah oh
okay nothing
down
i go down down
well we we've all had times when we
weren't our best selves and that's
something that fraggles silly creatures
gorgs and everyone and everything else
has in common so how do fraggles get
past that does all of the singing and
dancing help with that sort of thing
it does you know it really does but you
know i think what we try to do and maybe
you silly creatures do this too as we we
reach out to one another and yeah and
talk to our friends and and tell them
what's going on inside our hearts yeah
it's all about connection and yeah and
checking in with each other and talking
things through you know there's always
room for everybody here in fraggle rock
so even though we have our differences
we we tend to work him out yeah
we talk and we listen to each other yeah
very important
that is very important well gobo you've
talked to the gorgs before how scary is
it to face the gorgs were you ever
scared with how much bigger they are
than you i'm going to step away for this
because you're afraid
well the gorgs are you know listen i
mean i i'm not going to lie to you like
silly creature christina radish i was
pretty scared at first but but you know
what it turns out junior gorg and i have
a lot in common you know and i got to
understand him a little bit better and
and and i learned that just because he's
different than me doesn't mean that we
don't have something in common to talk
about you know
but i'm not gonna lie i was uh
i was uh terrified not scared at all you
know i was totally blessed
yeah totally brave thank you very much
we were terrified for you were you you
know what you did oh you talked it out
well you know i just i decided to reach
out yeah you know he seemed like he was
upset and i wanted to i wanted to help
well that was beautiful thank you
yeah
well moki i've heard that you like to
meditate first thing in the morning so
what do you like about meditating and
how did you learn to meditate and do
yoga and all those sorts of things oh
christina you know i am self-taught
i uh but i'd love to start my day off
with a little meditation it clears my
mind and helps me begin my day with a
clean slate as it were it's calming and
centering and just really helps me face
the day
do you ever get do you guys tried it
yeah i was gonna say do you guys ever do
yoga together are there yoga classes in
fraggle rock
yeah i've tried let me just say that
christina i have tried yeah i perfect i
perfected the art of staring into space
and blanking yeah just go like this
let's just say it's been semi-successful
radishes
postcards that's not meant for your
sticks clear your mind
clear your mind think of nothing okay
let me think
nothing
nothing
nothing that doesn't work no no no no it
does not
well the trash seat the trash heap seems
very wise what is the best advice you've
ever gotten from the trashy
well i will say the best advice i ever
got was when the trash she told me to
dig deeper
because you know i mean first of all i i
wasn't really paying attention what was
going on you know so she wanted me to
think a little deeper inside of myself
so there was that dig deeper but then
she also really meant dig deeper like
like pull the rocks away and and just
keep on exploring that that's right it
was metaphorical and literal at the same
time yeah both of those were really good
like that yeah
well thanks so much you guys i hope to
someday get down to fragile rock to see
you so i appreciate you talking to me
you're always welcome we'll take you
right there to the pond any radish is a
friend of a fraggle that's right
we love you silly creature fraggle
radishes yeah fraggle radish patina
radish
thank you so much for talking to me
thank you see you soon
you